you know um carrying on and on and on
about these videos uh mo brooks of
course is still trending
um and one reason why is because he's
like no no no no it wasn't me it wasn't
me it was my staff my staff did it they
did it it was them it was them i don't
know anything about it but you probably
want to ask them
you probably want to ask them because
that's you know that's the whole
narrative here with this rolling stone
article that's what i noticed about it
did you notice this that the reason why
the rolling stones article is so
significant i think is because it really
points out the reason why congress wants
steve bannon to be deposed
you got it steve bannon wasn't in that
story but that's the reason why congress
wants steve bannon deposed
is because there was a line of
communication you can see it in the
article very well with the quotes that
were given from the two people that have
been given immunity
and apparently there might even be a
third but there's two people and they
keep claiming that they're organizers
and protesters or something their
[ __ ] their seditionist is what they
are i don't i don't care if they were
duped into this they are [ __ ]
seditionist
they were going to commit treason they
wanted to overturn the government of the
united states a duly a duly elected
president was going to be certified that
day and duly elected by the people of
the united states and certified by the
states
they were just sort of they all they
were doing was a ceremonial yeah the
states are correct we congress wants to
get their nut in which is not a thing
that has to happen for the states to
certify it doesn't matter
and the vice president didn't have the
power that they said they had but they
went with the eastman memo because there
was nothing left
there was nothing left
but the eastman memo that was the only
thing that that the cheeto dust mobster
and grandpa farty mcshardy and sloppy
steve bannon that's all they had left
was to manage to figure out a way to try
to get the eastman memo to work
that's why that's why john eastman is on
his heels now saying oh no that's not
what i meant by that memo no one in
their right mind listen to that
john eastman is saying who stood on
[ __ ] stage with rudy giuliani that
day
stood on [ __ ] stage with rudy
giuliani and trumpeted parts of his
[ __ ] memo to the crowd to incite him
to go to the capitol and carry it out
john eastman is now saying oh well
no one in their right mind would believe
the stuff that i wrote even you
you wouldn't believe the [ __ ] that you
wrote because you sure certainly you
certainly was propagating it that day in
front of a [ __ ] microphone
right before the crowd went and did what
you were laid out in the [ __ ] memo
you [ __ ] idiot
but even still by eastman claiming in
the public here that no one in their
right mind so that means uh michael
flynn sydney powell uh linwood and mike
lindell are not in their right mind
course we know that
that would mean that donald trump jr
eric trump ivanka trump kimberly
guilfoyle mark meadows uh uh
steve excuse me dan scavino
uh uh
alex jones
all these all these characters
all these characters that we had
and donald trump himself rudy giuliani
himself grandpa party mcsharty and
grandpa poopypants
they had to be not in their right mind
because that's what they did they
believed that was their last hurrah that
was the last thing
i mean goddamn they even said
just let the just let we'll get the
congressman to handle it
and that's what this is about
that's what the steve bannon thing's
about that's what the executive
privilege communication communications
about this is what mobsters do
this is what they do is
they
communicate through channels so that way
donald trump can say ha i never talked
to mo brooks or marjorie taylor green or
lowenborg
or i never talked to the proud boys i
never communicated with the oath keepers
i never communicated with these people i
i take pictures all the time people
people take pictures with me all the
time i'm a famous person
you remember this garbage
sound familiar well the reason why it's
so familiar is because he's trying to
they distance themselves by having
chains of communication like that where
a mr steve bannon would communicate back
to the president united states
that yeah i'll give him blanket pardons
yeah tell them that [ __ ] that's fine
tell them whatever whatever you gotta
tell them to make them lay siege on the
capitol so that they that that i remain
the dictator
whatever it is
whatever it is that it takes that you
gotta tell these people to do
because we seen in the article
that paul gozar was guaranteeing
guaranteeing blanket pardons to these
insurrectionists
the people that broke down the windows
that were making the plans to lay siege
on the capitol
why all why donald trump
and all his cohorts were watching
i'll go down i'll go down and march on
the capitol with you no you didn't no
you won't
the whole plan was to get these people
to do their bidding
that way they could stand back and say
oh well we didn't know we had no idea no
i no clue no clue that way if it went
wrong they could do what they're doing
now and if it went right
if it went right we'd all be [ __ ]
that's what they were hoping for mo
brooks marjorie taylor greene lauren
beaubert
andy biggs paul goes-r
so i think that's why the executive
privilege
is trying to which is not executive
privilege steve bannon does not have
executive privilege just because he was
talking to donald trump on a cell phone
call that's not executive privilege
that's how it works and joe biden slam
dunk that [ __ ] again did today
no it's not executive privilege [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
you
and and and by by donald trump claiming
executive privilege was a lawsuit not
steve i mean steve bannon is using
executive privilege as an excuse too but
by donald trump using excuse executive
privilege he is saying that there was
communication between steve bannon and
him
about january 6 and the planning of
january 6. well we know we know that
there was congress people out there
communicating and planning with other
groups
we know that so where was that
communication where was that chain of
communication
given to reassure
mango mussolini jesus the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
donald trump
where was that line of communication to
make the mob boss feel like he was he
was in good shape for the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup that they were going to
attempt
get the [ __ ] out of here of course it
was steve bannon
of course it was roger stone that's
where these chains of communications
were coming from
that's why they're going to want to know
this [ __ ]
and armed with the eastman memo
regardless of why he wrote it rather any
person in the right mind would would
would believe it or not
they weaponized your memo eastman and
that was the [ __ ] intent of it in the
first place
so
the january six select committee needs
to get get to work here and get to it
and the department of justice needs to
charge steve bannon of criminal contempt
of congress yesterday the day before
yesterday really [ __ ] it
they don't need a grand jury [ __ ] this
grand jury [ __ ] it's voted on by house
by the house who needs a [ __ ] grand
jury the house is the grand jury they're
the congress they voted on it that's all
you need to know charge him jail him and
jail him jail him until his trial [ __ ]
him [ __ ] him
all right let's move on uh adam mo
brooks's little thing
boo boo
uh the judge this must be the kyle
rittenhouse yeah
the judge in the car written house um
case
and it's uh
kenosha county circuit clerk judge
is the one that
uh granted the
the ability for um people not to be
called
victims the people he [ __ ] murdered
he's on trial for murder and yet they
can't call him victims
poor you oh poor kyle written house it
would be so unfair to him
if they call them victims okay let's see
uh
of course january january january 6
insurrection is trending
uh
the dave durbin is a racist and
minneapolis so that's probably the kyle
rittenhouse thing
it's pretty simple pretty cut and dry
kyle rittenhouse is a [ __ ] murderer
and the people he murdered are [ __ ]
victims that's pretty simple now he has
a right to defend himself in open court
i mean that is a that is a right that
you're granted in this country or you
have the right to a free trial
but that doesn't
that that still does not that still does
not just because you have the right to a
free trial and you can go through that
process that that's that does not
exonerate you from what you did right
out in the open
and what we know publicly that you did
it doesn't just like just like the
[ __ ] insurrection [ __ ]
we knew this it was all public they said
it out loud that's like jim jordan
trying to walk back that he talked to
the president that day i may have i may
have not i talk to him all the time i'm
always on the phone with him blah blah
blah blah blah blah
you know jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan you know that [ __ ]
another [ __ ] we need to vote
stay pissed and vote that [ __ ]
out go [ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote that's how you get rid
of [ __ ] like that jim jordan
matt getz go
[ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote crawl over hot lava if
you [ __ ] have to vote these
[ __ ] out
but here we are let's see let's see what
this january 6 insurrection because i'm
sure it's the same [ __ ] i've been
talking about here
oh
is there new is there new news or is it
news that we already knew
because the public's not [ __ ] stupid
and it's obvious what happened
how is this not obvious already
oh here you go
kid vicious
one may smile and smile and be a villain
william shakespeare look at these
[ __ ] chuckleheads look at these
[ __ ] idiots
[ __ ] boneheads
what a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads
i don't know why it's doing that why is
it giving me that stupid box i don't
know what that is
did you guys notice on my feed now
there's this little download button
i figured out someone told me the other
day about about this uh extension on
chrome because i use chrome
that you can download it's called like
sss twitter i think
and you just download to your chrome on
your on your desktop
and you can push download and it
downloads the video
yeah
yeah it does it's pretty cool i don't
get any kind i'm not this they're not
like a sponsor or anything i just you
guys might notice the download button
you're like what the [ __ ] is that what
what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] is that
tell us what the download button is so
i'm telling you it's a button it's
called ss uh here let me
let me let me get the uh it's
ssstwitter.com
i don't get any kind of thing for that
that's it's just really cool so you just
click the button and then you go through
the process and you can download it now
you have to be on a desktop it doesn't
work on like um your cell phone so
you're [ __ ] out of luck if you're on
your cell phone
but if you do twitter on your desktop
then oh
one of my favorites mayo is mayo out
there
i know you're out there somewhere male
she's probably watching
she's going to talk about the january 6
insurrection here we demand
accountability for
for this seditionist and terrorist
that's right
pretty [ __ ] simple
pretty [ __ ] simple
not
rocket science
it really is not rocket science
pretty [ __ ] simple thank you for your
tweet mail
you always get straight you know what i
like about mayo's tweets
she always gets like directly at the
point
she just
takes out the the [ __ ] dart and
throws it
exactly at the bullseye bam
every [ __ ] time
thank you mail
so this is this is all about um january
6. of course andrew here has a video
about mo brooks what's
up corrupt our election let's listen
into what this [ __ ] idiot said to
corrupt our elections yeah today is the
day american patrons start taking down
names and kicking ass
names and kicking ass are you willing to
do what it takes
to fight for america
do what it takes to fight what does that
mean what does that mean mo brooks why
do you got a bulletproof vest on will
you fight for america will you fight for
america
we american pancreas are not going to
take it anymore we're not going to take
it anymore
so what we're going to do is go take it
from the people who voted for the for
the president that was certified by the
states the president-elect that was
certified by the states we're going to
go take it from them
that we
american patriots are going to come
right at them
we are come right at him what the [ __ ]
did he switch his head let them continue
to corrupt our elections today is the
day american patriots does he have a
bulletproof vest on underneath here so
because that's what i want to know like
when did he put the bulletproof vest on
that's what i want to know when
when did mo brooks with mo problems
put the bulletproof vest on does he have
it on here
does he have it on here when he's
inciting the riot or only after he
incited it and knew that they were gonna
he's like oh [ __ ]
after after that rally god damn these
people are surely gonna start shooting
is that when you put the [ __ ] vest on
when did you think there was going to be
shooting here at this moment when you're
speaking in front of the mob
the mob of domestic terrorists
or
after you incited them and realized that
you may get shot which is it which is it
mo brooks
which
is it
and uh andrew here just quotes mo brook
um but he says now that two witnesses
have confirmed
that you met with the january 6
organizers multiple time
do you still stand by your statements
you made at 9 16 a.m on january 6th
today is the day
that american fake rich
start taking down names and kicking ass
mo brooks
you [ __ ]
you treasonous
gutless
seditionist
[ __ ]
they should be expelled every [ __ ]
last one of them every last one of them
that had to do with the planning of this
expelled [ __ ] expelled
i think they should just put them on a
big [ __ ] list
right like that's what we should do when
we find out that all these that the
members of congress had anything to do
with planning the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup and they really they were complicit
and not only complicit but they were
they may have criminal liability in the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup they should
all be put on the list that she brought
to the floor and nancy pelosi should
force the house of representatives to
vote to expel those [ __ ]
immediately
simple just write their names on a list
to expel bring it to the floor on a
motion motion to the floor
and vote those [ __ ] out get
them out
your traders they did it they did it
with lincoln
they they did it with lincoln
there were there were seditionists
that were expelled because they tried to
stop lincoln from becoming president
sounds familiar sounds familiar
do it then we can do it now get a list
of them expel those [ __ ]
immediately
immediately get him off the [ __ ]
committees get him out of the halls of
congress it's enough of this [ __ ] for
these [ __ ] traitor seditionist
un-american
fascist trump humping
q and on
fools
to have any kind of [ __ ] power in
this country it's it's enough of this
[ __ ]
this gqp [ __ ] it's enough
rip it
right 56 minutes 56 minutes past the
hour as they would say on radio 56
minutes past the hour
remember tomorrow
tomorrow we have the uh the podcast
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern live
live here on
on the twitter the twitch and the and
also on youtube
uh if you want to find where those links
are at you can go to thetonymichaels.com
or get a link in my bio
all those links are there for the
youtube the twitter the twitch also the
links for the spotify the apple are
there
uh they're there also they're also there
so you can go um
you go check that out because you can
download the episode
after we go live because i can't like re
i can't post it before i record it does
that make sense so i can't put it up on
the directories before i said it so i
gotta say it and then i gotta post so so
what happens is i do the the podcast
live
and then i take the audio and i just i i
download it to
spotify and apple well i download it to
one place and then they distribute it
for me that's that's part of like the
merch if you guys buy merch that that
program that does that for me it cost me
money to to do that to publish to the
directories so that's what some of that
money goes towards when you guys buy
like [ __ ] on stickers like this
uh the [ __ ] sticker or or if you guys
want to go get a stay pissed mug
stay pissed hashtag go [ __ ] mode that
would help out and also other podcast
news again i said this earlier but if we
have some new people uh joining us here
at the very end
we have a special guest on friday i'm
going to announce who that special guest
is tomorrow on the podcast so i mean
you'll know if you don't watch but if
you want to know who the guest is uh
first
go watch the podcast tomorrow i'm going
to announce probably at the very
beginning like i always give the
announcements i'll probably announce who
she is she's
you guys don't know who she is she's uh
she's got several viral videos that are
on instagram and the tiki talks so if
you if you're over on instagram or tick
tock and you're in the the political
side of instagram or tic tac then you'll
probably know who this is but i'll
announce who it is tomorrow and that
airs friday so how we do the special
guest episodes is we record them
beforehand
and then we post them on friday same
time same place three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern youtube twitter
twitch so check out the live show
tomorrow and then also catch the special
guest episode on friday